good morning everyone it is a seven
o'clock welcome to join us on the
breakfast show on Sky News live this
morning and set my calls on why for a
special program exactly three weeks
since Nicola bully dropped her children
off at school took the dog for a walk
along the river wire and then simply
disappeared as her family called for the
public to focus on finding her we'll
retrace Nicola's last known movements as
they happened later in the program and
the mounting criticism of Lancashire
police after it revealed personal
information about Nicholas struggle with
alcohol and the menopause now the Home
Secretary has weighed in it's Friday the
17th of February
three weeks and still no answers Nicola
Bully's family call for an end to
speculation and rumors and plea for help
to find her
the Home Secretary demands an
explanation from Lancashire police after
it revealed personal details about
Nicholas struggle with alcohol and the
menopause
the force refers itself to the police
Watchdog over contact its officers had
with the mum of two before she
disappeared
we'll retrace Nicholas steps this
morning as they happened on Friday three
weeks ago
also coming up nurses escalate their
industrial action announcing a fresh
48-hour strike the Royal College of
Nursing warns no services will be exempt
Richard visits Northern Ireland amid
growing speculation a new deal on
post-brexit trade Arrangements is close
the first candidates expected to
formally enter the running to become
Scotland's new first Minister as the SMP
reveals how the race will unfold
and the Hollywood Superstar Bruce Willis
has been diagnosed with frontotemporal
dementia
[Music]
morning everyone a special program live
for you today from Saint Michael's on
wire in Lancashire it's now exactly
three weeks since Nicola Bolly was last
seen after dropping her children off at
school and taking the dog for a walk the
mum of two's family have issued a fresh
plea for the public to focus on finding
her and to end the speculation about her
private life after Lancashire police
reveal personal details about her
struggle with alcohol and the menopause
the forces coming underground criticism
about those disclosures with even the
Home Secretary swella bravaman now
demanding answers we'll be live here
throughout the morning looking at the
circumstances surrounding her
disappearance and later in the program
we'll follow the same walk the 45 year
old took on that Friday morning three
weeks ago NC's been covering the story
for us throughout he's with us again
this morning it's just starting to get
like this is the river wire behind us
what do we know well this is Nicola
Bully's last known uh sighting this is
where she was with her phone
her dog Willow the Dog lead all left
around this bench behind us and what is
a very cold a very deep River wire
with a fairly steep bank and muddy Bank
on its way down to the river and it was
this it's only about two feet deep
though there on the edge around two feet
deep you go further into the river and
some local fishermen have actually told
us it can get up to about 20 25 feet
deep in some parts and it is a tidal
River the absolute nature of the river
wire means that this river flows back
and forth constantly and it's like a
strong tide no not right now but it does
move and it can move quickly in a matter
of minutes in fact if the police's
Theory their main hypothesis that
they've come up with and revealed early
on in their investigation that Nicola
bully accidentally fell into the river
wire then what they've said to me in the
last few days it is highly likely that
the mum of two has ended up at Sea
around 9 10 miles away from this point
into Morgan Bay and into the Irish sea
are there any scuff marks whether find
any scuff marks was there any blood on a
stone where she might have banged her
head or okay it's been three weeks there
wasn't a cord and set up around the
bench when Nicola bully first reported
uh Missing no there was police presence
here and significant police presence but
there wasn't a crime scene as you would
usually see Nicola bully was marked
initially as a missing person a missing
person of high risk why was she high
risk it was due to specific
vulnerabilities that her family namely
her partner Paul had flagged to the
police just clarify that the police had
been to the house two weeks before yes
so it was on the 10th of January that
police attended Nicola Bully's family
home they said that they attended on
reports for concerns for welfare that
was on the 10th the medical team went as
well yep there were police there there
was a medical professionals that police
said went alongside with them and that
was 17 days before Nicola went missing
what else happened in that 17 days we
are unsure of but what we do know is
that on that morning Friday the 27th of
January Nicola carried out her normal
routine dropped her kids off at school
and took her dog Willow for a walk along
the route that she would normally take
what happened in the 10 minutes that I
unaccounted for is still a huge have a
look at that should we in more detail
bear with me if you would please she
disappeared Friday morning exactly three
weeks ago look at what we do know as
Lindsay was saying there from the police
about her movements that morning she
went missing early on the 27th after
traveling from a home in Inskip to the
nearby Village of Saint Michael's on
wire she dropped her children off at
school in the village that's on garstang
road Nicola then set off on her usual
walk with her dog Willow 843 along the
river wire footpath a dog walker who was
familiar with Nicholas saw her walking
around the lower fields at approximately
8 50. we'll show you all of this in more
detail later on 8 53 she used her mobile
phone to send an email to her boss then
at 901 Nicola logged into a team's call
for work at approximately ten past nine
a witness somebody who also knows
Nicolas Aura on the upper field walking
her dog we're going to place all this
for you so you can have a clear idea of
what happened 9 20 her phone moved
towards the bench area which is just
behind us towards the lower field at
around half past nine the team's call
ended but Nicola stayed logged on onto
that call Nicholas mobile phone and the
dog Willow were found nearby on the
bench behind us and the foot bath next
to the river by another dog walker at
approximately
09 33.
um crime correspondent Martin brunt is
here with us as well but we don't know
what happened to her
no I mean the police have given us their
main working Theory
they've got into all sorts of trouble
because they didn't make it absolutely
clear when they announced that that
there were other theories that they were
still considering
um and they are still looking the
searches
keep going as he's been talking to India
about the movement of the river means
that when they clear some of the river
or they don't find uh Nicola they have
to go back at some stage because the
water has moved there's always I mean
that's that's not beat around the bush
when they say she went into the water
they're now looking for her body and
because of the water movements
um bodies can move so they clear one bit
of the river but they go back because
they think that perhaps her body might
have reappeared at an area that they've
already searched they've talked about
land searches around the coastal area
12 miles or so from here they finished
those land searches but the sea search
continues and it's not a forgiving Coast
that as I know from you know being this
part of the world not the easiest
searching a River Estuary is is
complicated I mean it's difficult enough
in a in a fast-moving River the coastal
area will present all sorts of problems
but they've got expert help it's not
just the police and they're divers who
are looking they've got fire service and
rescue they've got Mountain Rescue
Services that have been helping
rnli all sorts of expert help
and they say that they're determined um
to keep going and we've seen actually
boats out on the water all the way down
to the mouth of the river working their
way up the river wire where it's
incredibly tidal we're down at the sea
it is incredibly choppy as well so you
know if that is what they're looking for
a body in the water Nicola's body it is
incredibly difficult to do so but you've
been in touch with the family uh
constantly they don't think she went in
the water no the family want absolutely
every possibility explored you know the
police were very quick to jump to their
main working hypothesis that Nicola fell
into the river wire immediately the
family went hold on we want to make sure
the police's mind is open and that the
public who are still searching for her
that their mind is open as well they
want to make sure that absolutely every
Avenue is explored but okay look for a
family three weeks they're missing a
daughter they're missing a sister a
partner a mum they have gone through
absolute hell over the last three weeks
it has been a roller coaster ride it's
been an absolute turmoil and all they
want is Nikki to come home yeah so much
to talk about about this case isn't it
we're going to try and unpick it a bit
more throughout the course of the
program for now guys thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot Nicholas family have
uh said this it's now been three weeks
since Nikki went missing we as a family
believe that the public Focus has become
distracted from finding Nikki and more
about speculation and rumors into her
and Paul's private life due to the
perimenopause Nikki suffered with
significant side effects such as brain
fog Restless sleep and was taking HRT to
help but this was giving her intense
headaches which caused Nikki to stop
taking the HRT thinking that may have
helped her but only ended up causing
this crisis the public Focus has to be
on her and uh not making up wild
theories about her personal life
joined this morning by wire Council
leader Michael Vincent Mr Vincent thank
you for taking the time to join us this
morning
thoughts
be very sad that we're three weeks on
and it hasn't been found
in fact our thoughts with the family
it's been a very difficult time for them
more than anybody
um it's been quite difficult for the
people of St Michael's as well obviously
with all the uh intrusion visitors and
all of the all the horrific things that
have been going on around the case so
it's been it's been a very difficult
three weeks for many years social media
seems to have played quite a role in
this case definitely yes and I mean
you've spoken then about the police
being criticized
um all this investigation has been
conducted so so far in the public eye
everybody seems to have a theory on
social media everybody seems to want to
know all of the information we learned
yesterday obviously that the police
share of clearly more information with
the family for being criticized because
they didn't then share more information
with the public than they otherwise
normally would so it's been quite
unprecedented I think in terms of the
interest in it I mean we're we're here
at the scene of a missing person three
weeks on from the day so I've never
known anything like it
um there's been a lot of criticism for
the police yeah where are you with that
uh I think that there are lessons to be
learned but I think that they've done
their best and very difficult
circumstances would you be concerned
with that sort of information about one
of your loved ones being out in the
public Arena uh I wouldn't like it but
as we already know from the statement
they put out yesterday that was put out
there with the knowledge of people's
family in because other people were
seeking to make that information public
and that wasn't the police's decision of
their hand was forced should they have
done it
um again with the benefit of hindsight
that should be looked into for future
cases but I I think they've I think they
have done their best in very difficult
circumstances but if it was important to
the case should we not have known about
it earlier
perhaps and that's that's something that
perhaps is fueled some of the online
speculation and some of the interest in
the in the story but again I think with
the police have done what they could in
difficulty quite surprised were you that
they didn't cordon off this area as a
crime scene potential crime scene
um
quite but it's quite difficult to
coordinate I suppose and been a public
footpath and being people coming and
going into time between a bit of tape
around it perhaps yes uh again that's
that's something for them to look into
to learn some lessons from that how is
this community going to start to rebuild
from from what's Happening well the
community has stayed very strong it's a
very small place less than a thousand
people yeah indeed and they they've
rallied around they've they've been
incredibly strong for the family for the
children of the village and they've
carried on looking for Nicola in the
right way they've carried on trying to
raise awareness stood on the highway and
sort of held pictures of her to try and
raise raise the memories of people who
perhaps have driven past on that day so
um the community has stayed strong
obviously finding Nicola would be would
be welcoming and helping to move on from
from this incident but I think the
community has proven itself to be a very
strong Community as you know Sky News
has been covering this story throughout
we decided to come up today to really
focus on on what may have happened and
when you come and have a look at this
obviously I've been talking about it for
a long time looks pretty innocuous yes
yes it does um when the police first
contacted the council about it they
didn't make clear though that while the
river looks very calm on the surface it
is quite strong tidal current underneath
so it does look innocuous the river does
look very calm very peaceful but that's
quite deceiving
and what other involvements have the
council had with the police have you
been able to help them and we try to
just raise awareness and try and get the
message out to people not to come to St
Michael's
um the local councilors have described
how busy this area has been at the
weekend has been Lake Windermere on a
busy Summer's Day hundreds of people
um tried to discourage people coming to
to somehow carry out their own
investigations which has been happening
and and just to try to stop some of them
more
darker elements of of the Public's
interest in this yeah people being
arrested for going into people's back
Gardens with flush torches in the middle
of the night haven't you've seen that
there's no houses immediately around
here but Pete houses just nearby as
people have reported being sat in their
living rooms in the afternoon watching
television and people coming up to the
windows peering and trying the doors
it's been terrifying for them there's a
typically elderly people
um extremely scared in their own homes
the residents have had to employ an
external security company that's just
not acceptable didn't know that yeah
okay and how are they have you spoken to
them
um the local councilors have kept in
regular touch with residents
um again the community has stayed strong
people typically stayed strong and
they've they've been very resilient in
these sort of difficult times and they
do they have found it very upsetting and
very distressing do you need to look at
what you might need to do to make this
safer place
possibly yes I think you can always
you can always learn lessons from
incidents like this obviously the bank
is quite steep it's getting the balance
right though between what is potentially
one terrible incident and people's
access to the river and the ability to
walk into fish and and to do all the
things that they want to do on the
rivers but it is something you're going
to look at yes I mean we we aren't
necessarily responsible for would be
responsible for fencing it off as a
Borough Council but we would work with
Partners to look at what we can do
across the board to make The River Why
more safe for people yes it's good to
talk to you thanks for taking the time
to join us bear with me one second if
you would please thank you well
Lancashire police facing mounting
pressure over its handling of the
investigation after it revealed personal
information about Nicholas struggle with
alcohol and the menopause the Home
Secretary swella Braven has demanded an
explanation Additionally the forces also
referred itself to the Watchdog over
contact its officers had with a 45 year
old before her disappearance on
Wednesday night police revealed that
Nicola bully suffered significant issues
with alcohol which had resurfaced in the
months before she disappeared earlier
this year a response car with police and
health professionals attended her home
following a concern for welfare it's
been revealed that police have now
referred themselves to the independent
Watchdog over the visit two and a half
weeks later Nicola bully disappeared at
some point between 9 10 and 9 33 in the
morning she was reported missing to
police just an hour and a half later
the next day police drones helicopters
and dogs began the search for Nicola
three days into the search Lancashire
police said for the first time that they
did not believe her disappearance was
suspicious
a week after she disappeared police
announced that they were working on the
hypothesis that Nicola had entered the
river a team of underwater dive
Specialists joined police in searching
the river wire but failed to uncover new
evidence following intense public
interest police issued a dispersal order
in Saint Michael's on wire where people
were conducting their own searches
on Wednesday police had a press
conference and revealed that Nicola
bully had specific vulnerabilities which
means that she's classified as a
high-risk missing person just a few
hours later the force revealed personal
details about Nicola including that she
struggled with alcohol issues and with
symptoms of perimenopause Martin and NZ
still with me uh Martin if that was so
important why didn't they tell us to
start with
because it's not the sort of information
about a personal information about a
victim that you would normally disclose
my feeling is that Lancashire police
were so stung by the criticism about the
focus of their investigation which was
that Nicola had gone into the water
rather than have been the victim of a
crime that they um
they invaded the privacy of her family
and of her in order to save its own
reputation I think that's what's
happened I mean they began at the press
conference by talking about her
vulnerabilities without going into
any great detail which I think was fair
enough but why on Earth three or four
hours later they put out that
astonishing statement that went into
real real detail about alcohol problems
menopause concerns
um is is beyond me and Beyond most
commentators I mean the force has been
widely condemned by all sorts of people
and I think there's even a sense that
the family although the family must have
known did know that some of this
information was going to come out I
think even they were astonished at the
reaction that it's provoked and perhaps
with hindsight think well maybe the
police shouldn't have put those kind of
details out well they certainly feel
Nicola wouldn't have wanted yeah and the
shadow Home Secretary and the Home
Secretary both wanting answers yes
Lancashire police are under the cost
um I mean they're being investigated or
they may be investigated over their
initial contact with Nicola and her
family on the 10th of January we've
already talked about you know the
welfare concern that Drew police and
health professionals to the house 17
days later Nicola vanishes so it's um
it's standard practice really that the
police Watchdog the iopc would look at
what happened on the 10th of January to
see if the police did everything they
could to see if there's a connection
with what the police did or didn't do on
the 10th of January and Nicholas
disappearance on the 27th and the Home
Secretary quite rightly wants to know
why police said what they said two days
ago interesting to hear from the council
leader saying we need to look at this
whether it's safe or not and they're
definitely going to investigate it yeah
well I think that is something you know
working on the police's main hypothesis
that you know this is the area that
Nicola ended up in the water then
clearly it is something that they're
going to have to look at this path you
know we have seen dog walkers by the
dozens and dozens over the last three
weeks it's heavily populated with dog
walkers uh obviously a small village but
people come from far and wide to walk
their dog here it's a it is a beautiful
part of the world there's no denying
that but clearly there is an issue by
this bench it's very muddy here it would
be very very easy to slip and okay I
don't know if you can actually see but
in the river
there are parts of the river where there
is some un quite disconcerting uh
whirlpools of water that signifies that
there are quite deep parts of the water
of the river wire here as well so you
know a huge worry if it is the case that
Nicola ended up in the water if I make a
I've been speaking to Nicola's family
all throughout the last three weeks I
interviewed her sister her Mum and Dad
just days after she went missing Sky
News has also heard from her partner
Paul as well
um but a note coming in from her father
um whilst he's watching this morning he
says we've had an incredibly hard few
days
um and it is just fingers crossed that
what we're doing today raising awareness
of Nicholas still missing three weeks on
helps them get some answers but that is
a family still really struggling to come
to terms with Nicola being missing for
three weeks now okay I know you're going
to be with me throughout the morning
gentlemen for now thanks so much indeed
also still to come on the program for
you speaking to Simon Harding a former
met police detective Chief Inspector for
his assessment on how Lancashire police
are handling the investigation and
nurses are escalating their industrial
action with more strikes next month
speaking to Chief exec of NHS providers
sir Julian Hartley and at just after
eight speaking to Labor's Shadow foreign
secretary David Lammy
we'll have all the latest from St
Michael's on Wyatt throughout the
morning but first let's take a look at
some of today's other news for you and
some breaking news in the last few
moments the latest retail sales figures
show retail sales volumes increased by a
half of one percent in January after a
fall of 1.2 percent in December of 2022
the RS says the rise was driven by
January sales promotions for online and
non-food sales though the cost of living
and food prices continue to hit food
sales
and some more breaking news this morning
NatWest has revealed its profits surge
by more than a third to reach 5.1
billions last year as it ramped up
mortgage lending and took in more income
amid higher interest rates
the Royal College of Nursing has
announced its biggest walkout of the pay
dispute in England the union has said no
services will be exempt meaning the
strike will involve for the first time
nursing staff working in emergency
departments intensive care units Cancer
Care and other services let's get more
with Becky joining us from the
University College Hospital Becky good
morning
yeah it's a dramatic escalation okay as
you mentioned nurses working in a e
departments in Cancer Care they will be
striking and NHS leaders have
understandably expressed their alarm at
this now previously because of
industrial action in the NHS uh since
the end of last year around 140 000
appointments have been canceled that is
nothing to be taken lightly but this
time you could see patients in need of
potentially life-saving treatment in
need of Cancer Care and that care is in
Jeopardy now the nurses Union have said
they will provide life and limb cover
they are in discussions with the
government about what that will look
like but they have said that they will
provide the absolute minimum Staffing
and they have said that the NHS should
look to other clinical professions other
unions to cover for them but even if
that cover is in place this strike could
have potentially deadly consequences for
patients now this of course has all come
about because talks are between the
Union and the government about pay and
working conditions are not getting
anywhere the Royal College of Nursing
has accused the prime minister of
refusing to negotiate and we're seeing
similar things across the public sector
but of course with nurses with NHS staff
the stakes are so much higher if you've
got patients showing up in need of
urgent care and that care might be in
jeopardy
okay for no thank you well the Scottish
national party says it will announce its
new leader on the 27th of March after
the surprise resignation of the first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon no one has
officially thrown their hats in the ring
yet but several candidates have ruled
themselves out of the race including the
snp's Westminster leader Stephen Flynn
Deputy first Minister John Swinney and
SMP Joanna Cherry according to reports
the Scottish Health secretary Hanzo
Youssef is considering entering the race
Mr Youssef is the first non-white and
first Muslim cabinet minister in the
Scottish government
which is in our kids in Northern Ireland
today amid growing speculation he could
be close to securing an improved
post-brexit deal with the EU it's
understood the PM will meet political
parties to discuss fixing the Practical
problems on the ground our political
correspondent Rob Pyle has them all Rob
yeah this certainly looks okay like we
are in the end game here of this lengthy
protracted process to try and find some
sort of settlement to fix some of the
issues relating to Northern Ireland that
stem from the brexit deal that was
signed by Boris Johnson Rishi sunak and
his Northern Ireland secretary flew to
Belfast last night they'll have meetings
today with political parties and other
involved groups Richie sunac will then
fly on to Germany to Munich tomorrow
where there's likely to be more meetings
with European leaders at the same time
the foreign secretary James cleverley is
heading to Brussels today for meetings
with EU leaders so all the parts look to
be moving into place I think the most
critical meetings the most important
meetings Rishi sunak will arguably have
today will be with the dup unionist
politicians in Northern Ireland who are
refusing to allow storm on the devolved
assembly in Belfast to sit in protest at
what they see as Northern Ireland being
carved away from the rest of the United
Kingdom as a result of that brexit feel
if those Democratic institutions are to
get up and running in Belfast again
Rishi sunak will need to get the dup
um on board he will also though need to
square his conservative back benches so
yes big practical issues to solve as
well but big political issues and big
political risks for Rishi sunak as well
okay thank you
the Hollywood star Bruce Willis has been
diagnosed with frontotemporal dementia
according to his family they took social
media to they took to social media I
should say to announce how his condition
had Advanced a 67 year old Die Hard
actor announced he was stepping back
from his career after being diagnosed in
March of 2022 with Aphasia a condition
affecting the brain which causes
difficulty with language and with speech
hello again everybody welcome back to St
Michael's on why we're bringing you a
special program this morning three weeks
to the day since Nicola bully
disappeared NC is with me as you can see
bitterly cold this morning as it was
that day it was it was really cold that
Friday the 27th of January
um it was you know a winter morning it
was muddy here as it is quite often
actually but this is a route you know
covered by many many bog Walkers and
it's a route that nickel a bully took
pretty much almost every day we saw some
CCTV images from her front house the
ring doorbell showed her leaving the
house putting the the dog Willow
daughters into the car she then set off
around 10-minute Journey from Inskip
dropped her kids off at school and then
went on her daily routine of taking
Willow for a walk and she would end up
around here that morning she was on a
team's call with her uh with her company
that she works for as a mortgage advisor
and then what happened in a 10 minute
window and on a counted 10 minute window
which police are still trying to get
questions over is the huge question
right now three weeks on what happened
to Nicola bully in that 10 minute window
yeah I know the family have been
speaking to you this morning I've also
had the local cancer leader on the
program he was saying they're going to
look at here I mean it looks pretty
innocuous but once you get into that
River it is tidal and it's it could be
up to 20 feet deep in places so he says
we're going to look at what can be done
to try and sort that out it's an
important point that as well Kate
because you know over the last three
weeks a lot of people said oh well I
don't you know it doesn't really seem
it's flowing fast it looks quite calm
but actually it's a tidal River so the
nature of it means that it moves back
and forth constantly and police were
adamant that you know that is the case
if say Nicola went into that River as
their working hypothesis is she will
have moved significantly in 21 days and
potentially well highly likely police
actually say is that she will have ended
out let's see when you just go around
the bend here the Meander of the river
wire here you get to a wear the wear
then picks up a lot of stream and you
see the water starts moving pretty
quickly and then when we've gone you
know further down the river as it gets
wider and wider you see it moving really
quickly in some parts of the water going
Upstream in some parts going Downstream
and you see big pieces of debris moving
in that water as well so the police have
been scouring that water using water
drones using divers specialist diving
teams they've used boats on the water as
well on underwater cameras to really get
a sense if they can find any evidence in
relating to Nicola going missing yeah
also hearing for the local councilor
that local
households have had to employ private
security because people have been trying
their doors knocking on Windows and
there's been an awful lot of interest in
what is happening here we've just had a
statement from lancashire's police and
crime commissioner that is Andrew
Snowden he says first and foremost my
thoughts remain with the family and
friends of Nicola buddy and I'm thankful
for all the efforts of the officers
staff and partners who continue to work
tirelessly on the search for Nicola
the investigation Into The Disappearance
of Nicola is under the direction and
control of the chief Constable the
unprecedented we haven't heard from him
by the way the unprecedented media and
public interest in this case whilst
welcome for appeals for information is
challenging for the family and friends
of Nicola and officers and police staff
dealing with unsubstantiated rumors and
speculation on a daily basis I'd like to
thank all members of the public Who
provided helpful information to
Lancashire police the police are being
as transparent as they can be on what is
an incredibly sensitive and complex case
that includes continued external support
from the National Crime agency and
others as appropriate joining us now
former met police detective Chief
Inspector Simon Harding
um hello to you thank you for joining us
on the program
um your thoughts on how this case has
been handled by Lancashire police over
the last three weeks
well I think I think it does sort of
look at two Avenues really one is the
the messaging which has probably caused
I mean what you could Now call a bit of
a circus really isn't it around
um Everybody turning up and uh and and
speculation in in some parts of uh the
media and some and and a lot of people
on Tick Tock and all those various
social media channels but what you
really want to see is is that the
investigation in the background is being
conducted properly and there is there is
some doubt around that as well
unfortunately simply because originally
when the three hypothesis came out that
which is quite right from the detective
superintendent
Smith that you that you she could be
either in the river which is which is
still true she could still be in the
river that's you know everyone should
understand that that's one of the
hypotheses and also she could have left
of her own accord that area and we now
know uh from the the uh press conference
on Wednesday that there is a possibility
there are Roots out of there which
um are not covered by CCTV so and I
think it within the actual press
conference itself the superintendent did
mention that it just the day before that
press conference that they'd identified
a path which um that doesn't have that
sort of coverage and and is a possible
route out now that that was a slight
worry because obviously the area hasn't
been
uh poured and off as we say and so you
know those those are the routes in the
past that you would want probably
fingertip searches on just to just to
make sure so everything should still be
on the table all those hypothesis
and and probably the the the reason why
it's gone a little bit array for them is
because it just felt like they were
pushing into just one of those three
yeah I mean I walked down that path
actually this morning and I wasn't aware
until
um a couple of days ago that there was
no CCTV that was covering uh that path
or the entrance or exit to it I wondered
why the dog wouldn't have followed her
if she'd walked along the path but there
is a kissing gate here so potentially
the dog wouldn't have been able to get
through uh if she'd wanted him to stay
behind but the police are still
confident that their working hypothesis
is that she stumbled down the bank
behind us here or in some other way
found herself in the water
yeah and I think you know that's it's
it's phraseology sometimes you know the
work the sort of phrase we use about an
open mind uh is that everything is on
the table until you can actually take it
off the table so if you have direct
evidence factual evidence that that she
has gone in the river then of course
that would be your
um your main one but
um I think because they're suggesting
that there isn't evidence that she's
she's left all been taken by a third
party for example then that's why those
are still on the table however there's
as much evidence of that that she's left
her own accord through that pathway for
example then there is that she's gone
into the river so I'm sure they are and
I can see that they are doing lots and
lots of work in the background and
having the NCAA as they've said uh by
this side and other partners who will be
helping is a is a reassurance in in some
part too
okay um should we have seen more from
the chief constable
well it's not for me to say really but I
mean I think the person that I always
wanted to speak you know or hear from
brother was um the sio because you know
having been an sio I always think that
the family wants to see you because
you're the person you're the you're the
front and center of this and and those
are the people I want to see quite often
when you have those almost like
figureheads of the assistant chief
constable and the chief Constable come
out it's more of a corporate reassurance
and and top cover as they call it but
you know you want you want the person
that's dealing with a day and day out of
the inquiry and obviously the chief
Constable won't be doing that but
they'll be being briefed as I'm sure now
uh members of parliament are being
briefed as well uh on a daily basis of
any developments that might happen due
to the nature of how this is uh how this
has grown
and would you have been comfortable
releasing the sort of information that
we have heard about Nicola over the last
couple of days
no I don't think I would have done but I
think that's that's probably down to
that original media strategy where
you're almost justifying why you know on
a personal level and as a team level why
you believe more than anything else that
she's in the river and I don't think
that was necessary if you if your
original strategy is just that you give
weight to all three of those scenarios
then of course people were expecting you
as as part of one of those to be in the
river they're expecting you to get CCTV
and getting dash cams you don't then
have to elude you know you know in the
background what your favorite one is
because of her background but
um you wouldn't necessarily have to have
pushed it into the public Arena and I
yeah I think that's probably uh the
worst thing that's come out of this now
especially talking about alcoholism for
example linked with the menopause I mean
you know there was nothing to suggest
that she was uh drunk or anything that
morning you know having driven her kids
to school and uh went through her
routine and met people and uh logged on
to calls and arranged dates and all
those sort of things so so the necessity
the necessity of saying that is probably
for me
um unnecessary
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
joining us thank you Martin's still with
us
um we're here three weeks on
um no sign of her hasn't been for um the
whole three weeks the dog was here the
phone was here the lead was here
where'd the police go from here they
continue to search
um you know it's difficult to see them
ever bringing a halt to the search but I
guess inevitably they will um get to a
point where they will stop the search
this may be many weeks off
and then leave the case open and be
prepared to react when any new
information or evidence comes forward
but you know we may be a long way from
that I mean at the moment you know for
all the control controversy they've
stirred up over the way they've handled
it in a media sense they say they are
absolutely determined to carry on the
search they still as far as we know have
40 detectives working on the case and
perhaps as many as 20 other officers
they still have a range of experts
search teams available to them so at the
moment there doesn't appear to be any
let up in their Endeavors to find Nicola
but they don't think that they'll find
your life
I think hopes of that happening must be
fading very fast and I think also for
her family they must be coming to coming
round to the idea that perhaps they
aren't going to see her alive again but
I mean the important thing for the
family is that they've been shown no
evidence there is no evidence that she's
even come to any harm so they will as we
all would in those circumstances cling
to the hope
you know in the absence of any bad
evidence that she is for whatever reason
somewhere alive
and there is that area that we will walk
along um later on that doesn't have CCTV
coverage so she could have moved away
from the bank without being seen
in theory yes but as far as the police
are concerned they have no evidence no
information
that she left the riverbank which is why
the very strong focus of their
investigation is that she stayed within
this area
and
extrapolating from that their theory is
again not backed by any hard evidence
that she went into the water and it's
interesting the language the police have
used I'm not aware they've ever talked
about an accident or her falling into
the water given what they've already
said now about the state of her mind you
know her personal issues and clearly
their focus is on the idea that for some
reason tied up with perhaps her mental
health issues that Nicola perhaps
decided to end her life that's where the
focus is but again there's no evidence
of that there is not for now Martin
thanks so much Martin again going to be
with us throughout the morning as we
focus on this part of the river while
were three weeks ago at Nicola bully was
last seen she has not been seen since in
a statement the family has said she has
been had been struggling with symptoms
of perimenopause including brain fog and
Restless sleep it's after criticism over
the decision of Lancashire police to
disclose very personal information
Ashner has been looking at the impact
the menopause can have
like millions of women Nicola bully had
been coping with the adverse effects of
the perimenopause details shared by her
family remind us all of the physical and
mental strain it can have but also of
the lack of awareness
for many people it comes as a surprise
and a shock
um because it can be very varied but
also we have a situation where for some
of our particularly some of our GPS our
practice nurses Unfortunately they have
never had formal education about
menopause the menopause happens when
women's periods stop usually between the
ages of 45 to 55 but can start earlier
there are over 30 symptoms including
insomnia and night sweats but these
hormone changes can impact mental health
too for one in Four Women the symptoms
are debilitating and for women with
perimenopause they can happen up to a
year before the menstrual cycle stops
Nicola Billy's family say that she had
been struggling with the perimenopause
and had started taking HRT to try and
cope but that in itself started causing
some severe side effects it's a reminder
that whilst this is a widely available
treatment that can be effective at
relieving symptoms for some for others
it can have a very different impact
the women's and equalities committee has
long argued that not enough is being
done to protect menopausal women
we know that the menopause will affect
different people in different ways for
some it will be much more severe than
others and I think the real challenge
around the menopause is that people are
given adequate medical support and
assistance from professionals and not
stigmatized
solving those challenges means tackling
that stigma famous faces have been
campaigning for the cause for years
until their voices are heard for half
the population it may continue to feel
like a silent struggle Ashley Sky News
hello again everyone it's three weeks
since month two Nicola bully disappeared
at this spot here on the river wire
despite an extensive search by
Lancashire police involving more than 40
detectives hours and hours of CCTV
conversations with up to 700 drivers dog
walkers who use this path regularly
there has been no sign of Nicola we'll
have continuing coverage throughout the
morning and we will retrace the steps
and the walk that she took from the
school car park where she dropped her
two daughters off to the point where her
phone was left on a bench still
connected to a call
what's happened to her nobody seems to
know at this stage continuing coverage
as I said here on Sky
meantime the Royal College of Nursing
has announced its biggest walkout today
Nurses at half of hospitals mental
health and Community Services will take
part in the 48-hour strike from the
first to the 3rd of March the union has
said no services will be exempt meaning
that for the first time the strike will
involve nursing staff working in
emergency departments intensive care
units Cancer Care and other services
joining us now is the chief exec of NHS
providers sir Julian Hartley hello to
you sir Julian thank you for joining us
it's getting serious now
yeah it's it really is uh serious
um very very worrying obviously in terms
of the potential impact uh the scale of
this is more extensive with 93 trusts
involved the duration 48 hours including
overnight and of course as you have said
the fact that the derogations have
changed that's the exemption so you know
for example itu
um obviously itu is a key area in in any
major hospital it's all about
um not just major trauma but of course
very important operations Cardiac Care
uh neurosurgery
cancer surgery and of course emergency
departments and Cancer Care as well so
although the RCN have said uh they plan
to work at a national level to make sure
that there is life preserving care uh
trust leaders I know are extremely
concerned and worried about the
potential impact for patients on on this
uh this next round of action
and it's not just that
the 38 hours it's 48 Hours continuously
what we saw previously was nurses going
on strike for 12 hours and then coming
back to work how concerned are you that
you are going to be able to cope
well there'll be a huge amount of
planning now uh we'll kick in there'll
be all of the work to think about
contingencies and how we do protect
patient safety and care but obviously as
you say the fact it's overnight as well
so the Intensive monitoring for example
of patients that goes on continuously
night and day finding ways to make sure
that that's managed and
um taken care of that there are so many
logistical practical challenges
not just actually in hospitals but
across the whole of the NHS in other
organizations as well that are affected
obviously in Community Services mental
health and so on so this is really quite
a significant development and I know
thus will be working hard to protect
patients but the other thing to say of
course is there'll be a significant
amount of care disrupted so planned
operations we've already seen a hundred
and forty thousand
um Admissions outpatients and so on
being disrupted and we're likely to see
another large number at a time when the
NHS is driving towards reducing the
backlog of patients waiting for hair and
treatment and so it's a it's a key time
for us to focus on those priorities
which I know everyone in the service
wants to do
and what's your advice to people who are
concerned either for themselves or their
loved ones who may well be using the
services of the National Health Service
during those 48 hours
well people should still attend as usual
unless they hear otherwise
trusts will do everything they can to
manage and mitigate the risks there is
likely to be disruption and patients
should wait to hear from their hospital
if if that's the case if they don't hear
anything they should attend as normal
but obviously over the coming days
there'll be a lot more work I know at a
national level to work with the RCN to
look at that issue of derogations and
where
um where that ends up but I just
emphasize that um trusts will be doing
everything they can to try to work
through this to protect patient safety
that is absolutely the top priority
good to talk to you thanks for taking
the time thank you thank you
three weeks ago today
Nicola Bully's phone was found on that
bench the dog's lead was found on the
bench the dog was here Willow running
around but there was no sign of Nicola
bully if we look from our other camera
you can see the river wire it's it's a
beauty spot it's where a lot of dog
walkers come she had seen quite a few
dog walkers who well certainly they have
contacted the police to say yeah we saw
her she was doing this she was in the
upper field she was in the lower field
but what happened to her before 10
o'clock since that day there has been
absolutely no sign of Nicola her family
are out of their minds worrying about
where she is she's a mum she's a partner
she's a sister she's a daughter and
they've waited and waited to try to
discover her fate the police say that
they feel that she entered the river the
family say that is not what has happened
and they just want to come home
continuing coverage here on Skype